rumors about the Nintendo NX have been
flying around for a while but now we're
hearing reports about the wii u
according to Japanese newspaper Nikkei
Nintendo will cease production of the
wii u by the end of 2016 and cue the
jokes about the wii u being the new
dreamcast nintendo hasn't released an
official statement yet but Nikkei has
been correct about its nintendo reports
before and it's no secret that the wii u
hasn't sold as well as its competitors
or even its predecessor Xbox one has
sold 18 million units ps4 has sold 36
million units and the we sold a hundred
million units compare that to just 12.6
million for the wii u and if this report
is true that's pretty much all it'll
ever sell previous reports say the NX
will launch this year and nintendo
certainly wouldn't stop manufacturing
the wii u if it didn't have something
ready to take its place we'll have to
wait for a full statement from the
company in the meantime for all the
nintendo news you need you're already in
the right place